up down up down
salad the game and here we find Barney
Walker getting his makeup done he's
gonna look so fabulous just like if you
physically can't see I'm not an heir
from Jaws I would look young Barney come
on use those tagging experiences you had
on the streets of the neighborhood be I
want to spray paint your don't anyone
who doesn't know Naperville will get out
your web it is like Leave It to Beaver
realize there you go oh that's great
yeah you know
and action notice right also I ghost
okay got it go okay very good that's
good for that let's see the next scene
all right
I just feel about that Jim fine it was
actually nice and cool on the floor all
right yeah the next is the is the
graffiti scene so dick you're like
you're just gonna spray-paint the wall
Marie Alfano
do it do it yeah that's awesome
the night well I'm gonna stop the foyer
so yeah yeah you can L d'bari yeah wait
what you have she has thank you with the
like nail firmly believe me I almost
made it at 2:00 a.m. but sometimes you
have to sleep for three hours before
sometimes you know so sometimes girl you
look amazing yeah you look good Jack was
late find an alpha like hers I was like
take which one got you
yeah what's good everybody yeah
everyone's gonna get a next thing right
but you got your collarbone so got my
collarbone the bosoms get the KJ hey
Jason
yeah yeah what about these creepy
mannequins oh wow Jim Jim did it again
hollingers look at Slippery our best
you guys we all need to go to a
convention yeah absolutely I like it a
couple cameras in me read the show we
have to show them the shimmy shimmy yeah
yeah I got fans on his first time being
on a nostalgia critic shoot
oh maybe we'll try later what about you
hmm yeah we're getting a more diverse
casts leave those are 29 bucks or
something like yeah 25,000 yeah that's
25 ways oh there you go why are you
calling you creepy mannequin oh no whoa
wait a minute I thought about that
thought about this thing yeah this
anyway yeah it's a fish-like oh yeah
mannequins mannequin and human love it's
finally happening
you're prettier you're breaking new
ground in life too
yeah you're groundbreaking
groundbreaking you guys actually I feel
like this is how I feel like this has
happened before though yeah sure love is
it true hmm yes so Rob is our new
graffiti artist yeah he said surf and
painting graffiti yes for you Rafi I
just really want to write a larger yeah
to fray that kids who didn't live
through the senses baggalini knees won't
get it there we go yeah drip baby drip
there you go oh that's great yeah did
you not oh sure
yeah yeah okay okay
I'm actually really offended because
that was your decision to call me a
bitch
as a demisexual toaster fair enough take
your bread take baby cry say I'm listen
I think it right go ahead wait for them
to sort of like yeah yeah like very slow
moving a milky see that movement oh
really good that won't look good yeah
okay perfect
we're cool so we got that okay I think
we're gonna do yellow do green screen
next one
ghost good reaction and be very very
good
okay so the first one was good at least
okay uh Heather Yahoo we're gonna get
you in this white robe this is when
you're in the hotel but why she's gonna
get with ghostbusters here so go ahead
start getting to it up with you I'll
just uh yeah I can make it one awesome
your reaction to seeing yourself in the
mirror like that sounds you me out there
that's how you made can you even
recreate it
yeah you look good thank you
yeah you all look so good Jimmy did it
let go ahead uh let me get some uh let
me get you all in here we're just going
over the scene while they're still
getting okay oh it's awesome you look
like what the construction sighs just go
with it and then you all start to walk
off that way whatever you say your wife
it looks like Twizzlers last sodas with
somebody yeah so my gorgeous white
wiggler if I look let's hit this uh I
think somebody should say I feel like a
traffic oh look I can what I feel like a
traffic cone I know I make this I like
all the way they made you look like a
reflective construction sign just go in
it I can throw it actually look there's
like a scanner get that walk off just
paying there or just put it like right
next to move it just heaven they should
all just be staring at it like this seem
familiar guy if I put it right next to
them or like it's you're placing on the
best end we've hugged young realize note
that wasn't even me
yeah no Abby is that you know that's
just know I'm over here like I said it's
butt ugly line
it's kind of going right no no no no I
got it but I go and look at that just
what the hell are you staring fucking
like whistling this butt-ugly leg right
Abbi I'm over here yeah
yes that's brilliant
okay yeah I just noticed it around so
you wait a second wait wait a minute
no that's nice on that and it's like
this no not you you know what let's do
that let's have instead of the being
lassoed by an orange and white Whistler
Lenin I I don't know what it's and I can
throw it in furniture
I know why they may look like you were
last by orange and white khun's odds
twins let's just go with it
and then you just say this sucks does it
Abby I try to go top all right oh that
so that will be coke around it work
correct after I sell know why they made
you look like Boyd you're white
Twizzlers Lanson you just go and do a
run-through yeah and then uh yeah this
sucks does Abby uh I'm over here oh yeah
let's yell E and as I let's go stop
traffic yeah let's go bust some traffic
yeah yeah traffic Buster's bustin trip
yeah I say uh you should say I think you
should do like that let's go
just a bunch of chen jicheng okay little
run through real fast yeah you guys are
busting ghosts does it make you feel
good
and it makes you feel good good we all
just absolutely they're there all we
really sweating right now
nice I even have that shit all right
sweating it's hard it is I got it a
power nap there
Oh Crouching Tiger Hidden Princess you
know what are you best thing it is it
keeps playing person in Chinese whenever
there's a problem were just like gym it
up Jim it up
that is really ghost girl let mean
graveyard girl no your dad you see gone
okay we got the song good all right okay
look you have you cool grab Joe rust
that's good
I mean it wait do I have this but I know
look at that I don't forgive me it looks
strand on it I don't think of you so it
just adds like to do a little hook like
you're just cornerback mm-hmm official
ghost to bust your rope holder okay all
right
well jump
you didn't do them but you were there
well yes it's just like it's a fairy I
can't seriously venue a considerable
assent techne of these gentleman system
I'm not an heir from Jaws look like what
you look young Barney it was like sure
that's hanging up on the wall in your
house and I'm not the more heavier phone
down you're gonna bring it out okay
ready and action
I looked a real bad comment about you I
posted my disgust on a message board you
better look out I've got a real nasty me
coming no way huh dregs a little dinner
I was great uh yeah I don't like that
that'll be a bit
all right y'all ready
Malcolm phone away oh all right you're
so used to it all right you all ready
and action
I love to real mean comment about you
posted my disgust on a message board oh
you better look out I'm gonna read you
one asking me huh I can watch you all
you ever great while I got you here I'm
gonna weep and thank you but to internet
extremes partake in the ultimate battle
good I'll put a stretch up automatic old
hey comic wanna sit and actually let two
internet extremes partake in the old
submit back great Malcolm I'll get yours
real fast here just anything just guests
all right y'all ready and thank you
yes sis's sis's silence okay y'all ready
and action
yes the ultimate battle ostrich egg I'm
ready ultimate battle yeah thanks Brad a
set and action yes
the ultimate battle great little deeper
okay he almost devil a demon battle
yes I can set and action
yes the ultimate battle could even just
a hint slower good for Narnia when it's
up and actually yes
Oh battle beautiful velvet legends intro
okay the 15 is 17 I think this is
arguing pop me my brother I don't know
if I'm ready to be a min inist again
about you man oh yeah yeah I've got it
I've got my shirt in my bag and act
who's Buster hit up name is Lana hi
money here bacon evasive ring I said I
said oh I'm so sorry baby I'm sorry okay
and actually who's busted head of limits
Lima hi Mia oh damn that's what I think
take a look at this you must pardon me
my breath I'd envisioned see happy
thought she warned more justice
yeah yeah the way you glad the way what
do those beautiful it's okay y'all ready
yeah feel nervous having a man next to
me he maybe massages to this is amazing
okay yeah all right
quiet on the set already did rolling the
mic is on me it would assume okay and if
you say I think not wait like let's say
wait for him to start tracking in their
quest all right
ready and action I think not what shut
this off shut this whole were you off
the hell are you
I will not allow you to just like okay
alright
rolling come on I'm net and wavy you say
the entire phrase between Big Bob I
think not
and action I think not shut this off
shut this covert Bureau who are you this
is social justice pet defender of
everything social justice see I will not
allow you to dislike the new
Ghostbusters moving you raging
misogynist okay I can't keep a straight
face a day okay I'll just take it from
who the hell is this okay alright
hey it's Frank okay dating super yeah
okay alright ready and what the hell are
you
this is social justice Beck defender of
everything social justice see I will not
allow you to dislike this new
Ghostbusters movie you raging misogynist
what I'm a misogynist cuz I thought the
trailer was like crap
the trailer was kamek gold just look at
this poster good yep on this one just a
tease
keep your distance on this one I can get
a few guys to keep this is on the nephew
wait I'll go try one more buddy just
don't look like you're stupid oh no my
casual and on just look at this poster
put your glasses back on okay just okay
you already rolling it quiet on the set
and action I think not shut this down
shut this open so this how are we down
well you I thought you're gonna go into
some sort of wine is there things no I
just go what okay okay - yeah I ready
and action
I think not shut this off put this over
beer off
I pull the hell are you this is sulfur
justice Peck defender of everything
social justice II I will not let you
dislike the new Ghostbusters movie you
raging misogynist
although massages because I thought the
trailer look like crap the trailer was
comic gold just look at this poster good
yep cool got it will switch out the
battery of your fest and one two three
I'm gonna say one two three turn you are
not truly authentic okay you're not
DiGiorno naturally authentic oh yeah
sure thing so it's an official pin well
then back a bit could you can always
zoom in so much that's nice
it's up alright oh look at my thumbs and
chicken all right how did you see yeah
maybe me would check it out they're
bringing some very Street I like that's
a good life hi guys I was just like this
is this is gonna go over well maybe just
in there in the dark does won't ya don't
know anything we're gonna miss my famous
night sense
okay everybody ready all right we're
moving cause I'm sorry from link here
again are we not know from the whole
thing okay from the top
yeah all right quiet on the set ready
and action
he's right one two three leg hair it
doesn't matter whether you like or hate
the film what matters is that it's your
opinion and it wasn't forced on you
beautiful beautiful okay so so you two
are gonna be facing that way light like
you've just come in like you just sort
of like you know like you walked up and
you just turn okay so they say this way
okay yeah facing that way and then for
camera and Malcolm your gun wants to
thank you Oh so start on him um yeah
soon as it goes because he's gonna say
the first line but we're finishing off
with his so as soon as I say action just
sort of get to him pretty fast to get to
him yes you can start with him but you
can sort of yellow Hessler that's the
first I do okay how ghost monster
doesn't hate suspense it goes crazy idea
Ghostbuster kissing no not Tom there's
no become a living it's just fear okay
because white on the set so I'm just
starting and going immediately like this
yeah I say I'll leave a little bit more
speak you like um you know get their
chance in there too because a
Ghostbuster doesn't hate all right okay
cool
looks right ready all right y'all ready
and action because a Ghostbuster doesn't
hate a Ghostbuster doesn't discriminate
Ghostbusters stands for peace and
freedom the freedom to think what you
want to think love for your fellow fan
or hatred it's your choice
that's cool dog on the way I was just
thinking what these guys what's that I
might mouth away just ready for one more
yeah we'll do it one more yeah all right
that's a look at you yeah I miss
continuing to roll
so okay all right you guys are dust
organized my stairs
they're not real ghosts freshman you're
a girl so does bustin make you feel good
it does take all of this off because I'm
sweatin like a sow so you get to bust
out of this Jam we really about to bust
yeah it's supposed to go slower I know
you don't need no more snow
we're dead there is something strange
not in the neighborhood but in the
studio in this neighborhood
yes neighbor oh ma I love you baby I
always have I'm keeping that in I know
that way though we now retire the great
s Jake Flynn creep this gee it's coming
back ice that's Walter Peck to you I'll
have you know that I'm respected in the
APA you thought it was fun to make fun
of me well that's my channel shut it off
dunk was EGIS like it that's out
it's weird rather you really transform
when you just put on this like there I
get it now there is something really
liberating about playing this guy if I
could mix my jeans you're gonna be green
and the artist yeah is liberating how is
yours it's a telemarketer dick it's
great yeah it feels it yeah like future
looks like I got license to speed Django
and them may not like my normal usual
jaggoff yourself cuz normally I'm a
fucking jag
but like now I get a license feel real
Django real hood let out your inner jag
run free what one two three four up up
down down up up down down up up down
down up down salad the came up
pick yourself up Malcolm this thing came
up really I don't think he's gonna come
up again a little more just say hey why
did you get that one you suck and here
we find Barney Walker getting his makeup
done he's gonna look so fabulous that
looks more even than before oh how is it
sitting in the chair
oh boy son Irving homey I'm going to be
an Ewok cousin
looking good looking good I used to
think he wants for baby whooping you
know I'm pretty sure I did too it's
almost kind of working yeah yes I'm
horrified how much is it you're kind of
looking for him it really it's a good
Ozzie yeah it's spot-on here we're
working on it no I'm impressed
I'll do any more just like TV ha ha see
dad is Ozzie but it's like oh wow almost
kind of work shit go I'll shoot your bit
okay I'm going to film the little last
bit of the Black Widow off work on a
film set
oh sure yeah creeping around the corner
that's what Malcolm's doing so I will
get a serious one first you'll serve
Peter on JP I know yeah I'm looking like
uh yeah it's like the whole crowd were
doing the ecto cooler flying on and
stuff so pretty much just halogen
so the ekdum color brings everyone
together yes yes it does something good
the only thing we can all agree on is it
ecto cooler okay
quiet on the set first why miss and
first learn I'm gonna be in the shop man
okay mmmm all right you ready and
actually no great I will do one more
thing to do it try again
so still serious yeah still serious on
this one all right quiet on the set
ready Malcolm and action no great oh
this one will still have the smile okay
grind his head ready and action
no I had no idea which one the
government it's so confusing that he's
smiling by the same time it's like he
would kind of do that dy yeah so it's
like yeah that's gonna be hard with that
put that together so you're good -
perfect Malcolm and when I said you were
also done yes za zc shoot and we will be
done why won't be done now I'll be done
for the day I'm gonna shoot the review
part tomorrow and like all my other
stuff oh good I think it's about time
that I retire for the night kids but
I'll be back in your nightmares
yes nightmares and Reno's oh yeah but I
know synonymous okay I don't have to
change pants oh I've got hope to go over
this okay alright nice job
damn it pretty nicely done
like I know why in the movie he doesn't
have the glasses on but that that's such
a trademark oven - yeah yeah you kind of
need it yeah yeah I think so
how bad okay that last one like that
that's very good
sieving just making a little louder okay
ah but that's it's on the right track
all right I'll do another one here you
ready yep and action
uncle fucking friend Elliot topic whom
the fucking dreams of Daniels alright
let the fucking Prince of Darkness I
would've been real with a few years ago
hey even I know what a banshee chatter
oh my god are those clowns Asian
swimming around your bubala now that's
our uniforms but I thought I'd brush
crazy-good since he is eating me at just
a bit more on which man trying to think
you would do like The Godfather or no Mr
Wong depression I never did come on it
is it try it just try doing a solo say I
am the love do it ready credible
direction pull in okay quiet on the set
so now from the beginning ready mm-hmm
and actually I'm the fucking Prince of
Darkness a few years ago I wouldn't rip
realm that you know good well might just
a lesson but but everything else is
really good
alright what will fucking Prince of
Darkness a few years you go out with a
bit more relevant okay just a little arm
whispering I was the fucking Prince of
Darkness a few years ago I wouldn't bit
more relevant you know yeah even I
would've and she shot but God a little
cloud initiative swinging around your
boo-boo
no that's our uniforms
that I saw try interest crazy-good
do their life sign one more time I have
to count like when you looked at the
camera all right you ready yeah oh and I
saw my dressed crazy I just want to say
an adjutant oh my god okay oh and I
thought that I dressed crazy good one
more let's start the turn I hit earlier
oh oh and I thought I dressed crazy good
one more like that
oh and I was fortunate I trust crazy
that was great
that last one was so yeah okay and the
quiver that little quiver yeah that was
a God the reason I knew you could do it
is that Stallone impression yeah I
remember you try and you say you splice
it I can't do Stallone but you're
imitating Judge Dredd after you saw do
like I can't tell you about this movie
and you're like I can't do Stallone but
he just comes out and live all this
stuff she goes oh yeah the law and I'm
like oh that's too low I can't remember
that voice it's a good point
times oh yeah no like that was
incredible direction colleges
oh the Newark well I say and in the new
one oh good yeah original it Oh fine of
it it's just so they find that the new
one is better in a way yeah the new ones
a lot you know yeah I'm tired I'm gonna
get a car some years ago son you're like
negative karma DL I I am I am made of
tired right now I've been here since
6:30 most opponent yes and I'm so well
Jim do the proton packs tonight very
last night so I didn't say I'm always
thinking about you yeah I know that ever
since I took the mustache off I just
don't have that douchey thing going
anymore so I'm happier but that is your
mo I'm just tired
can you hold your finger to your upper
lip we'll have the same good X I've been
out of comic long time now I just feel
like Hitler people think this thing goes
Zach I'll is it yeah there is some truth
when I had the mustache out of just like
once I took it off I'm like if you have
you know I look at him here and I didn't
have this stupid eddo stairs I'm like
yeah there's some of that it just makes
you want to be even douchey oh you
better like pornstache you can have a
joke so I want to know more about what
you do here it's been a lot of wild
speculations and rumors in the media and
I'm here to assist and the environmental
impact now you I will show me that
contaminant or that storage facility oh
I will get a court order on why that
wasn't credible everybody well that's a
very hmm
Rob sphere that's a ground shut this
down spin up this all down
you